moving on
our main story tonight concerns
conspiracy theories voted definitely
true by
uncle quarterly now you're probably
familiar with at least some conspiracy
theories like the claim that the moon
landing was faked
or the argument that the earth is flat
and that scientists are covering it up
and that is a theory that led to this
absolutely
stunning youtube video
[Music]
clearly
magnificent and putting aside the
factual inaccuracies slant rhymes
shoehorned lyrics and the bad adele or
solid bjork impression
my favorite part of that is the comment
holy crap this is amazing
i'm going to share this around the world
which is quite simply
perfect but as you probably guessed the
reason that we need to talk about this
is that the coronavirus has created a
perfect storm for conspiracy theorists
because their theories are now
everywhere over the last few weeks
some people have been saying online that
the virus is harmless
or even that it doesn't exist numerous
sites and
groups online have been falsely claiming
that this virus is a result of some sort
of biological warfare some sort of
bioweapon
or even created by the pharmaceutical
industry to try to sell more vaccines
one particularly persistent falsehood 5g
mobile networks transmit covid 19.
you know when they turn this on it's
going to kill everyone a woman in
britain called workers
killers for laying 5g fiber optic cables
when they turn that switch on bye-bye
mama okay there is
so much wrong there but most of all the
only time an english person should be
saying bye bye mama is when they're
physically leaving the womb
bye bye mama thank you for an excellent
delivery and after that is yes mom no
mom and thank you kindly for wiping off
my shameful buttocks much obliged
and those theories are just the tip of
the iceberg here you might have seen
this video of two doctors making a now
debunked claim that covert death rates
were exaggerated because it was all over
facebook a couple of months ago or maybe
you came across
pandemic a pseudo documentary filled
with a hodgepodge of conspiracy theories
in just one week it was viewed over 8
million times
which is a shockingly high number
because that means it's been seen more
times than this tick tock of a cat
matching a piano's pitch
[Music]
good cat you deserve more views
and the problem is some online theories
have already prompted
some worrying real world actions take
the hashtag film your hospital which
spread
after some claims that the severity of
the pandemic was being exaggerated
and urged people to expose the truth
that unfortunately
led to videos like this one where a man
angrily demands hospital staff show him
their coronavirus patients and then
shouts at them as he drives away maybe
you can call the governor and tell him
about the hoax
yeah it's a hoax where's all the
patients
where's the lines of sick people
yeah she's right and can you imagine how
confused that man is whenever he tries
to check into a hotel
no vacancy where are all the guests
what are the depressed salesmen
attempting autoerotic asphyxiation in
your lobby
maybe you should call the governor of
this best western and tell him your sign
is a hoax
and the harms of conspiracy theories
during a pandemic go
far beyond confused hospital workers as
one study pointed out
given the transmissibility of covid19
these beliefs are dangerous even if
only a fraction of americans succumbing
to them ignore best practices
such as social distancing so tonight
let's talk about conspiracy theories
particularly
why they're so appealing how to spot
them and what you might be able to do
about it and let's start with the fact
that these theories are a lot more
popular than you might think
polls over the years have shown that
over half of americans
consistently endorse at least one sort
of conspiratorial narrative and look
i'm not immune here embarrassingly
there's a part of me
that thinks the royal family had
princess diana killed i know that they
didn't
because there's absolutely no evidence
that they did but the idea
still lingers because it felt too big an
event to be accidental there had to be
some intent there and experts will say
that that is actually a huge draw of
conspiracy theories
they help explain a chaotic uncertain
world and
appeal to the human impulse to what's
called proportionality bias
which is the tendency to assume that big
events must have
big causes take the jfk assassination
that event
shook the world and the very idea that a
lone gunman
could cause such chaos was inherently
unsatisfying so people
perhaps understandably reached for a
much bigger answer although it is
revealing that conversely
less impactful events have attracted
significantly less speculation
the attempted assassination of ronald
reagan was a similar event in all
regards except that
the president survived it was a smaller
event
in terms of its outcome and therefore we
are satisfied with smaller explanations
and so there have been almost no
conspiracy theories about the attempted
assassination of ronald reagan either at
the time
or subsequently exactly and that kind of
makes sense doesn't it
one man suddenly changing the world is
inconceivable
one man failing miserably isn't remotely
surprising something which is also
incidentally
the tagline for feminism and the appeal
of conspiracy theories is such that
people can even embrace ones that
contradict one another
one study found that more participants
believe that princess diana faked her
own death
the more they believed that she was
murdered which sounds
crazy although if there is one expert on
something being demonstrably dead yet
technically alive at the same time
it was probably the woman stuck in a
loveless marriage with prince charles
for 15 years the point is
these theories have always been
appealing and have actually been
particularly seductive
during global health crises in the 14th
century conspiracy theorists claim that
jewish people were responsible for the
bubonic plague
in 1890 and newspaper claims the
electric light
was responsible for a global influenza
outbreak and in 1918
rumors spread that german pharmaceutical
company bayer had tainted its u.s sold
aspirin tablets with the so-called
spanish flu
the only difference now is that our
current pandemic is coming in the age of
the internet
when it's not only easier for people to
do bad research and spread their results
but it's also
possible for them to make material look
startlingly authoritative in fact
take pandemic at first view it looks
like a
high budget true crime documentary with
fancy graphics and drone footage
and it deploys those techniques to tell
the story of judy mykovitz
a former scientist at the national
cancer institute who's depicted
as a whistleblower on the scientific
establishment here is how the film
presents a key moment in michael vicks's
narrative where she claims
her enemies had her arrested without
cause and so what did they charge you
with
nothing but you're in jail i was held in
jail
with no charges i was called a fugitive
from justice
no warrant literally drug me out of the
house
our neighbors are looking at what's
going on here you know they search my
house without a warrant
now that looks pretty compelling there
the police surrounding her house using
violent force
and eventually throwing her in jail
without cause but
a few things you should know first she
was absolutely criminally charged as
stated in a lawsuit that she herself
later filed over the arrest
mykovitz was arrested on criminal
charges and when a reporter pointed this
out to her she said
she meant the charges were later dropped
adding i've been confused for a decade
and that i'll try to learn to say it
differently
second while that arrest footage looks
dramatic it is
not actually from her arrest at all it's
from
an unrelated swat raid and is literally
the first result you get
when you search house raid on a stock
footage website
which is just ridiculous because if they
simply worked a little harder and
searched house raid on other stock
footage sites
they could have found this video of a
masked robber spanking himself
then flipping the bird and dancing
around like a maniac
and that's not just objectively better
than the clip they chose it's also
exactly as relevant and the issue isn't
just
that the film misrepresents mike ovitz's
backstory it's that in doing so
they lend her an error of credibility
when they allow her to make
unchallenged batshit medical claims like
these
wearing the mask literally activates
your own virus
you're getting sick from your own
reactivated coronavirus expressions
and if it happens to be sars cove too
then you've got a big problem why would
you close the beach
you've got sequences in the soil in the
sand
you've got healing microbes in the ocean
in the salt water
that's insanity yes it is
everything that you just said is insane
the idea that wearing a mask activates
your own virus is absurd in debunking it
politifact said there is no evidence to
support this and then through in
we're not sure what a coronavirus
expression even is
as for the idea that there are healing
microbes at the beach look i don't want
to be the depressing guy that tells you
going to the beach won't cure
coronavirus but i will say
the beach is exactly three things none
of which are medicine
it's sand that goes down your ass crack
salt water that gets up your nose and
sun that burns your skin
the beach doesn't cure anything except
you being comfortable
and incidentally when we reached out to
the director of pandemic to cite our
many issues with the film he wrote back
not only saying that he stands behind it
but asking in a country that marches to
the chant of believe all women
why is it that people are so quick to
disbelieve doctor mykovitz to which the
answer is obviously a
because she's telling people good
coronavis prevention involves
not wearing a mask and going boogie
boarding b the phrase is
believe women not believe all women and
see
that's not what that phrase is about
because the point of that movement is
not
well i guess we all have to take rachel
dolezal at a word now and
look i am well aware that for some even
these criticisms of pandemic will
somehow be further proof
that what it's saying is true that is
actually a common trait
of conspiracy theories that they're
inherently self-sealing
with any criticism just becoming
evidence that the whole thing is bigger
than anyone could have imagined
although i will simply say this if i am
in on this conspiracy
that means my puppet master is a t and
what makes you think
that they can pull off a global
conspiracy when they can barely pull off
a complete phone call
how would they even be sending me orders
sprint
the point is these theories can be
innately appealing and
thanks to the internet can spread with
ease and all of this would be dangerous
enough
before you take into account that one of
the most prominent spreaders of
conspiracies on earth
is the current president of the united
states because he's been spreading them
around for years
often with the excuse that people are
saying them and he's just
asking questions something he's done on
claims like obama was born in
kenya
antonin scalia was murdered and that
millions of fake votes were cast for
hillary clinton
conspiracies are sort of like ugly
buildings and deeply tragic adult
children and that donald trump
loves to unleash them into the world and
then refuse to take responsibility for
them ever again
and he's been doing this throughout the
pandemic including
just this week when he retweeted a
theory that the cdc and the media
are lying about the virus to hurt his
re-election chances
trump has passed on so many conspiracies
that news outlets have repeatedly called
him
the conspiracy theorist in chief
although i would argue
he's not invested in any of these things
that he's spreading he's only interested
in amplifying whatever he thinks he
might personally benefit from and
i cannot believe i'm saying this but the
person with the clearest sense
of just how deeply cynical trump's use
of conspiracy theories is
is this guy when you get to trump and
his conspiracy theories
he does it in a really clever way
trump never says that he believes these
conspiracy theories
that he counts he simply passed the
amount
and it's it it's his way of jamming him
up it's his way of uh
teasing him it's his way of getting
these conspiracy
theories out there so trump is just
throwing gasoline on a fire here
and he's having fun watching the flames
yeah
rush limbaugh gets it and that's a
sentence i never thought i'd say unless
i was talking about toilet transmitted
chlamydia
but the thing is right now in particular
there is real harm in throwing gasoline
on the fire because
people are going to get burned making
those flames
not quite as fun to watch
because make no mistake here
people who have been convinced that
kovid was overblown have sometimes paid
a steep
price around this time last month
jupiter rideshare driver brian hitchens
was a self-proclaimed coveted 19 skeptic
i thought it was
maybe the government was trying
something that
and it was kind of like a kind of like
they threw it out there to kind of
distract us
fast forward to this week and hitchens
has a whole new outlook
from his hospital bed this is a real
virus
that you've gotta take serious
my wife's on the ventilator she's been
like that for three weeks
and it's tough it's it
it's sad yeah it is sad and
unfortunately
i don't think he's going to be the last
person in this country to learn that a
lot of what's on the internet is
the hard way so what can we do here well
social media companies are finally doing
more to label conspiracy theories or
limit their spread but the truth is they
can only do so much
they don't always have the expertise to
litigate what isn't isn't true and the
sheer volume of material flying around
makes it almost impossible for them to
catch everything and
that's actually been a challenge for us
in this story too we are clearly
only scratching the surface of what is
out there and i'm sure
if you look down at the comments section
when this is on youtube you will find
people saying
how about the fact that virus was
created as a bio weapon or what about
bill gates's plan to microchip me and it
would take
days to go through why each one of those
is and it still won't address
the ones that come up in the weeks and
the months ahead the fact is
it's going to be incumbent upon us as
individuals to try and spot these
theories
and treat them with a skeptical eye
before we believe them or indeed
spread them around and there are
actually three basic questions that you
can ask yourself that could help in that
regard first
is there a rational non-conspiracy
explanation because
remember the theory 5g towers are
spreading coronavirus
or as that one woman so memorably
phrased it when they turned that switch
on bye bye mama
exactly it made the rounds helped by
images like these showing maps of
coronavirus cases alongside maps of the
5g rollout and initially
the similarity there does seem striking
until you realize
those maps also look like the ones of
population density which makes
a lot more sense because that's
correlation
not causation wi-fi rollouts and virus
cases
will both be where there are a lot of
people in fact
lots of maps look like those maps this
one of domino's pizza locations
looks like a map of coronavirus
outbreaks and i'm pretty sure domino's
pizza
isn't causing it yes their wisconsin 6gs
will give you a dry cough
fever diarrhea and covito but not in the
exact same way as the coronavirus
and knowing the difference is called
science now the second question you
could ask is
has this been held up to scrutiny by
experts and if so
what did those experts say because it's
not uncommon
for theories to cite a single source a
doctor or scientist like
severely midwest and diane keaton here
making an outlandish claim
but it's worth checking if most credible
doctors or scientists
agree with them and if you're thinking
well what if all of them are in on the
cover-up too
that actually brings us to our final
question here how plausible
is this conspiracy as a practical matter
because not
every conspiracy theory is fictional
obviously some have absolutely turned
out to be true but the very fact that we
know about the real ones
actually teaches us something important
one study
looked at real government secrets like
edward snowden's revelations about
government surveillance and found
the reason they unraveled was because of
the sheer number of people
who had to keep them secret they
actually created an equation to predict
how quickly other science-based
conspiracy theories would have unraveled
had they been true
finding that faking the moon landing for
instance would have required an
estimated 411
000 people to keep quiet and would have
broken down in just
over three and a half years which does
make sense doesn't it because think for
a second just how many people
would have to be sworn to secrecy to
keep a coronavirus hoax under wraps
i don't know if you've ever tried to
organize say a midsize surprise party
for your cousin
but it's borderline impossible to keep
it quiet because
someone is telling roxanne no matter how
many emails you've sent saying
no one tell roxanne roxanne is finding
out
and i know you may not find conspiracy
theories plausible but you also
may know people who do and while you
can't reach everyone
you can reach some and and now more than
ever
it might be important for you to try
which clearly is not easy it is
completely natural to simply want to
scream at them why do you believe this
nonsense
you titanic idiot and i would
say
just show them this piece but obviously
i'm not the best messenger within the
first 20 seconds of this story
i called your uncle a and
tend not to like that
now what experts say is that the most
effective way to approach someone
is not by shaming them for believing
something or overwhelming them with
counter evidence but to try
and be empathetic meet them where they
are and nudge them
to think a bit more critically so to
that end we've asked some people that
they might be more willing to listen to
to help you start a conversation for
instance let's say your
confused grandparents are passing around
dangerous misinformation about not
wearing a mask
they may not listen to me but they might
listen to the man that they've been
letting into their home
every weeknight to calmly tell them what
is and isn't correct
hi everyone the answer is
alex trebek the correct question of
course
who is that handsome man i'm looking at
right now
yeah we got alex trebek to make a
90-second video
gently urging anyone who watches it to
be careful with what they encounter and
share online so you can show your
grandparents that
and then talk to them about it but let's
say you've got a cousin who's not a
jeopardy fan maybe they like wrestling
or
fast and furious movies well the good
news is john cena
has got something to say to them too
there's a lot of official looking stuff
on the internet
not all of it's true and there's some
stuff that
seems false but isn't like this one john
oliver and i are the exact same age
yep born on the same year on the exact
same day
it seems impossible that two human
bodies can
age so differently but it's true
i checked and it's important you do that
so before you go believe any theory
about the pandemic or share any
information about the pandemic
it's good to know where that
information's coming from yeah
both of those things he said are true
you should check information you see
online
and we are the exact same age it's a
thing that i think about
every birthday and it's not just alex
trebek and john cena we have an
assortment of truly beloved figures from
paul rudd to catherine o'hara to billy
porter each of whom
made messages to urge people to think
more critically here is just
a taste what's going on my people
it's me billy porter hello there i'm
catherine o'hara
i'm paul rudd alex trebek john cena here
wwe superstar actor internet meme
dessert lover
and number three on your partner's free
pass list i'm literally a superhero
the smallest one but it still counts i
know that we are living in scary times
given the current state of things you're
searching for answers about the global
health crisis
i think that's awesome that curiosity
that's good i'm curious too
if nobody ever asked questions jeopardy
would be a very
very weird show wouldn't it but you have
to be careful
because there's a lot of convincing
looking on the internet
and most of it ain't true you know i
once thought i was dead because
hashtag r.i.p paul rudd was trending
so before you go off and share something
with your friends and family
it's good to know where that information
is coming from is it a trusted news
source
if you're not sure look to see if other
trusted news sources and experts are
saying the same thing
a good way to know if an idea or story
that you've read about holds water
is that a majority of trusted sources
agree on it
and finally think critically you're
smart
you're smart you're a smart cookie i
know
i know you are we have the look of a
scholar and the taste of the macaron
y'all got brains use them use it like
it's the first roll of toilet paper
in a brand new pack unsparingly and with
gusta
you have common sense trust that part of
your brain to guide you as you educate
yourself during this difficult time
and trust that i'm doing what i can to
hop to number one on your partner's free
pass list
and number three on yours hey
be safe out there that's
all good advice and to increase the
chance the conspiracy theorists stumble
on them we've put their full videos
online
at thetruetruetruth.com and if you're
looking to start a conversation with
someone
picking one of these videos is honestly
a pretty good entry point
that is our show thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week good
night
you